8 news now investigator David charns is
looking into it for us and David we
understand his family previously warned
police yeah Denise the 80s now
investigators learning family told
police Tyson Hampton often pulled out
his gun during confrontations with other
people right now he is awaiting custody
on that he's in custody awaiting that
court appearance in the murder of Metro
officer Ty records revealing Hampton
pleaded no contest to a gun-related
charge just two years ago he was
involved in a family fight and
threatened a person with a gun a judge
sentencing him to a suspended sentence
meaning he didn't actually have to go to
jail he did have to serve community
service and before that police say
Hampton had fired around into a ceiling
in another fight now today's deadly
police shooting happening near the same
intersection of a shooting just last
month this is Flamingo and University
Center as Victoria was just there by
UNLV that is where a man shot at a Metro
officer and that officer shot back
killing him Sheriff Joe Lombardo
addressing these two incidents
it is in close proximity and it is an
area that we have been paying attention
to and here recently and and we're going
to ensure that we put all hands on deck
to ensure that we provide safety in that
community area so that part of town
seeing 17 homicides so far this year
compared to 15 at this point last year
overall crime though in that area is
actually down just a bit year over year
so right now if you take a look at our
crime map we have for you on
8newsnow.com you can see the zip codes a
crime by ZIP code that we have for you
here